hi my name is young lee and then i want
to talk about separating growth any
problem from lyric authentic or with
respect to npr tests so this is a joint
work with vga particularly from ies and
the mother society from ttic
and our problem is like this like a
fundamental rotating problem
so the input is m by n matrix a
and then our job is to find two vectors
m dimensional x and then n dimension y
both are like plus minus one vectors to
maximize um the quadratic form or like
by linear form x transpose a1
okay so this is a fundamental problem
um yeah and then unlike um some problems
like the um value of some soldiers make
it negative yeah but then one can easily
say for any matrix a the optimal value
is not negative so that the
approximation ratio is well defined
and then of course like this problem um
started by the second fundamental work
of chronic that essentially shows that
there exists some order one
approximation algorithm
for this problem uh via stp rounding
so since then yeah this problem has like
various applications um too many fields
including functional analysis converters
and optimization and then today we're
gonna study um the question what is the
best approximation ratio achieved by any
polynomial
okay but then like before diving into
the problem let's try to see like some
related problems generalization or
special case
um then and
see how our problem is different from
those results and then the first problem
you're going to see is a slightly more
general problem called the quadratic
expectation
okay so here the input is like the n by
n major say one can even assume that a
is a metric
and then we want to find just a one
vector um x
to maximize x transpose a x
of course one can easily say this is a
generalization of our problem
um
but then here like you gotta be careful
because like for example if a is a
negative
then the optimum cell um can be negative
so in order to use approximation then
like some assumptions are needed
uh and then yeah one natural way to do
is to at least assume the diagonals are
vanished
so if you assume that a i is a zero for
every i
then there exist some order login
approximately
um independent is covered by many groups
and then this is essentially tight
and our right rule
proved the almost magic hardness
okay so login is good
um and then the second problem we're
gonna see which is more relevant for
this talk is a special case uh called a
psd on quadratic maximization or like
little growth in the property
okay so here the everything is the same
as before
a button like max a is a promise to be
like pst matrix
for example a can be decomposed as like
b transpose b
for some other matrix b
okay so this is um yeah
this is a problem but then yeah one may
wonder still like yeah we are um
trying to find one vector
okay so how is that related to like our
problem which is like by linear problem
where like we are trying to find two
vectors
actually one can see that if a is
promised
to be pst
then finding one vector and then finding
two vectors are actually like the same
thing
okay so formally one can see that um
the maximum value of x transpose a y
where we search over like two vectors x
and y
um because like a has a admits this
decomposition
one can say that okay so then it's equal
to the the maximizing inner product
between b x and b y like this
uh but then we are like yeah the b x and
b y are in the same search space so it's
nothing but um
um searching like just like the one um
thing bx
and then try to maximize the sum l
square root
then it's nothing but uh maximizing over
like just one vector x
okay so yeah in this case danielle one
can see that uh if like a pst
then like one vector and two vector are
the same thing and that's why um this
problem is a special case for our um
growth in the problem where we are like
searching over two vectors for general
matrix
um and then for this problem i got the
pi over two approximation exists so
that's discovered by nester
and then i'll bring your gifts again i'm
sure that this actually is tight it can
be hard to do better than priority
by like any small constant
okay so those are like these like two um
special keys and um
general keys
uh but then our problem goes to the
problem has like a slightly more
interesting history
okay so this is our problem
um and then from the upper bound side
okay so we already said that growth and
gave a constant vector approximation
algorithm
and then for a long time the best
approximate ratio
was um this number
achieved by craving which is like
roughly 1.78
and then um
in 2013 braverman it rolled i'm sure
that this number is not um tight
and then actually can be the
one can get slightly better
approximation ratio
and then all these upper bounds are
achieved by stp rounding in a sense that
all these numbers
also give us the sp gaps upper bounds
for stp gaps
okay so yeah we often call like kg
as like the worst integrality gap
constant
and then um until now like the exact
value of kg is not known
but yeah we know that it's slightly less
than 1.78
okay uh from the lower bound side if you
look at kg
then davin raise independently give a
lower bound of kg which is like the
integrality gap for stp which is a
1.6769
which is like slightly known lower than
the best upper bound
so i can say there's a sum gap
uh and then if you look at the
computational hardness
then now quote nadal
um
proved that assuming the unit games
conjecture
so one can translate diabetes like more
stimulator bond to compositional
hardness okay so that they prove that
it's np hard to approximate this problem
uh better than dagger is constant
assuming uniqueness conjecture
and then shortly after ragavandra and
soil show that um we don't know what kg
is but then whatever kg is actually it's
gonna be np hard um to do better than kj
assuming in the game's conjecture
okay so that's the best known for unique
games and then in some sense like if you
assume unique games then actually the
problem is like sold we understand um
the approximation ratio exactly
but then still if you only want to um
base your like result on p is not equal
to np
then the best hardness is a pi over two
from little group ending provide
brilliant regular socket
um so there's like some gap
between what you can prove using um
np harvest and then what you can
prove using um uniqueness conjecture
okay so there's like some gap between
these two or even these two
and then
and then
yeah
if like unique games conjecture is false
then it
may be
possible that um the approximation ratio
of regrowth in the problem is equal to
the approximate ratio for the lyrical
tension
okay so if the unit gauge is false
okay so that um was a situation
but then our result
shows that
um actually it's not going to be true
okay so we show that it's npr to
approximate even the original growth
problem within a factor on pi over 2
plus epsilon for like some small but
universal constant epsilon
okay so the bond we got is um
only like 10 to the minus six but then
it's on optimize plus one again it can
not be bigger
so conceptually we kind of separated the
growth indic and then little good ending
i'm only assuming the p is not equal to
np
and then yeah we're going to mention
technique um
more in detail but then it's more like
global analysis
um
compared to more like local analysis to
typically use for unique hardness for
the other nprness so it may be useful
for like the problem itself or like many
other problems
okay so that's our like mean result and
then let me talk about um proof a bit
uh but then like before like directly
jumping into npr this let's revisit how
the ug heart is improved
and then get some inspirations from it
okay so of course like yeah if you want
to prove unique hardness um then the
first thing you got to do is i'll
construct a dictation test
so in our context
so declarative test is just nothing but
something like instance which is nothing
but a matrix a
but then we're going to assume that a
has like this special structure okay so
we're going to assume that a is a um 2
to the r by 2 to the rigids
so that the decision variables f and g's
are like um two to three are dimensional
functions
uh two denominators of vectors
then you know one can treat like f and g
as a boolean function
okay um
mapping um our dimension vector
plus minus 1 to the r to plus minus 1
then like that brings us to like a very
like on standard well
boolean function analysis setting
and then of course and then what we want
to show that if like f and g are
declares matching dictators
for example if the uh f and g are both
um indicated by the i coordinate
then yeah we want to say that the value
of this solution is pretty good say one
and then if the f and g are like far
from dictators then we want to say that
um
the value is known
okay so this is a typical requirement
for declaration function
and then of course i guess since we are
looking at the f and g as opposing
functions then yeah one can bring all
these like standard notions
uh from the boolean analysis literature
so for example yeah for um given any
function f
one can look at the frequency
composition
summation over all subsets as
the free coefficient of s
times the character of s
um and then yeah i'm going to define
this like the standard inner product so
f in the product g is the expected value
of f x times g x and then we can define
also p naught of f in the standard way
okay so this is our um standard
notations
um
given this okay so then yeah what's uh
what's our like first candidate
for declaration test
okay so first one is very simple it's
just like the degree one projection
okay so our matrix is f1
which can be considered as an operator
so given a vector f which is like
boolean function
then what fm does
is to leave only like linear on part of
f
okay so notice that yeah we are only
summing over like
the size one
linear um three coefficients
okay so um as opposed to
all
fourier coefficient
okay so this is a projection because we
are only like a leaving um linear part
of f
and then this is actually a dictator
a dictatorship test
okay let's briefly see why you should
like give something
so of course if f and g are declared
then one can easily say then f1 doesn't
do anything because like declares are
like linear functions
okay so then yeah g transpose f1 well f
is exactly one
but then um if f is far from dictator
suppose that um
each linear coefficient
is like very small say sub-constant
then um at least one if you look at the
value of g transpose am
since g is a plus minus one function
then the first thing we know i mean that
holds for every g m on plus minus one
is that um the value of g transpose air
is at most um the l1
over f1
okay so there that's um let's just say
because i got g is a plus minus one
function if like if g is exactly the
sign over f1 then actually we're gonna
get the exact one over f on n
uh but then yeah then there's like the
well-known pi over two theorem
um saying that if f is a far from
then the one norm over f1 f is at most
pi over 2.
okay so it's going to be like i mean it
depends on how far f is from dictators
so perhaps you should have a
little of one but then let us ignore
this
but then how is our subject improved
okay so the core intuition
is that um if f is far from dictators
and then if you look at the linear part
of x linear part of f
as a random variable because x is random
then value of this random variable
is a distributed like gaussian with some
variance
okay so this variance is all formerly
known as a
level one weight of f which is defined
like this
um yeah and then you're using this
intuition then yeah one can say that
okay so then um
the level one weight of f
should be equal to the inner product
between f and the linear part of f
and then as you saw like this is all at
most um
l1 norm of a linear paragraph
but then since some dll
f1f
is a distributed like a gaussian with a
variance like w1f
then the one number of this guy will be
roughly um
the standard deviation which is like the
root of w1f
times the l1 normal standard option
which like square root of a total pi
okay so yeah from this chain of
inequality then yeah one can see that
the
the level one way to wrap is at most
over pi
and that implies that the
l wonder of a linear part of f is at
most over pi
okay so this is roughly how this like pi
over two theorem is proved
and then yeah then actually we get like
some gap so exactly like what pi over to
get
from dictator
and then uh far from declared
okay so we got like pi right two gap um
by looking at just like the degree one
projection
um okay it's good and then yeah we know
that this um the the projection
uh our like instance here is a psd
and then that gives us like the pirate
hardness roughly
at least assuming on the unit beams
um
but then can you do slightly better than
that
okay so that's uh yeah that's the idea
of our diabetes and then this is like
kind of simple like this
okay so yeah just like you're looking at
the degree one projection
a was a pi over two and but then yeah
waterfall like just um
subtracting some copy of identity
okay so um uh in this case a f is going
to be like f one f
uh minus lambda times um i
times that
okay so that is our operator a
um and then of course if f is a dictator
then one can see that a f is a one minus
lambda times f
and then if the f is far from dictators
okay so then like from the previous
discussion then yeah we just said that
um the linear part of f
is a discrete like a gaussian with some
variance which is um
level one weight uh and then we prove
this is at most pi over two
but then we have this like part
minus some copies of identity
um
okay so then yeah again yeah we can just
upper bound the value of the g transpose
af by the l1 of af
but then now like a f is nothing but f
one f or minus lambda f
okay so at this point
so to get like slight advantage
over like pi over two we can one can
think about the one winning analysis
yeah so there are like two cases okay so
now like uh the quantity that we're
looking at is a linear part of f minus
lambda
and then the first case
is that if like f is equal to um
the sine of f one
with large probability
okay so then you know then one can say
that
so then like f and like gamma linear
part of f
have the same sign
which means that if you look at the f1 f
minus lambda then there will be lot of
translations
okay then it means that the l1 norm of
the
f1 f minus the lambda will be much
smaller
than the just like the
one
over f on n
and then what about the opposite case
okay so if like f is like um a very
different
uh from the sign of a linear part of f
then it means that then somehow like f
and the linear part of f are like very
different which kind of implies that the
linear um the weight
of f
should not be like a too big uh to begin
with
okay so those are like two like um the
intuitions going to different directions
and then if you combine these two
carefully then yeah one can that one can
shape like some constant
uh from pi over two and then that's how
um diagon reads i gave a slightly better
lower bound
uh which was a made mini game's harness
by code portal
um and then yeah finally um the
recommended trigger like i'll give
optimal hardness um the kg harvest so
i'm not going to talk much about it but
then i just wanted to measure that their
hardness is also this form
okay so the um yeah they got the design
numbers lambda 1 lambda 2 lambda 3 uh
from the stb gap instance
and then um they're like um instance a
is um is actually the same form it's
more general but then yeah you extract
the degree i term both m and then
multiply lambda
and then that's kind of generic family
of all recommended story instances
but if you want to prevent vrness
then um you got to be more careful
about um how you come plug in your
dictator test
with the outer wave fire in this case
like label cover okay let's first define
label cover
so in our context it's going to be graph
g
[Music]
and then labels at r
and then suppose that projection degree
is d and then um l is on r over d
uh then like for each edge of uv we're
gonna have like d2d constraint in a
sense that um for each like um the u and
v
we're going to partition the alphabet
set r
into like l sets over size d okay so
we're going to have like the
p 1 through p l
for u and then p 1 through p pl
for v
okay so we have like the l pairs of all
the sets
uh and then if you have a label
for u and label for v
then these like labeling satisfy the
edge e
if and only
they fall into the same like matching
block
formally there exists like some pair i
such that
label of u
belongs to the the i set
in the used partition and the label of v
belongs to the um i said in this
partition
okay so yeah this if you look at this
picture here
then the label set over u is a partition
in two sets rather than on yellow and
then so b is a partition two sets um red
and yellow
and then if you choose like the one
yellow label here and then one yellow
label here
then this um the edge is satisfied
um if we had um chosen a red label here
then this edge would have not been
satisfied okay so this is a label cover
like send our thing
and then of course the goal is to find
the labeling that satisfies the maximum
fraction of constraints
um and then yeah it's a standard result
and from tcp theorem and then parallel
position uh saying that it's npr to
distinguish whether the optimal value is
one or like nonstop constant
okay so we're going to use this result
and then so here's uh the reduction that
gives you like pi over two npr's
okay so um suppose that n is the number
of verses
okay so then like space we're going to
work um
is um
n times like 2 to the r dimension space
okay so which means that for each vertex
of the label copper instance we're going
to have like the one the boolean
function
which is our dimension
is that some what the n times two to the
r such as
then which means that they are for each
like a vertex um that we're going to
have a
boolean function fb
okay and then suppose that yeah if i
have like two on global um the functions
f and g then let's define the inner
product between f and g
as the inner product between f v and g b
or like a random vertex v
okay so yeah that's kind of the space
we're working on with
but then crucially let's define a
subspace b p
okay with some obvious notation yeah
let's also define p to be the projection
of the space
um whose linear coefficients are
consistent with the label copper
constraints
okay so formally of what we mean is that
for every edge
from uv
and then for every like a matching pair
of sets
so if you look at
some of the linear coefficients
of u
in this like set
p eui
then that sum should be exactly equal to
the analog sum for v
over the ice set in the partition of v
okay so yeah if you um see an example
here
then yeah this is like kind of like a
consistent with our like dictatorship
test um machinery
because like um if in the us case
if the label cover has a good label
so that each like our vertex is labeling
the label the test cells at every edge
then what we want to do
is to set um set the boolean function
for each vertex to be the dictator
dictated by the
the label which is a good label
okay so which means that if you look at
the linear coefficients as a vector
then this vector
should be like like standard unit vector
it should each have exactly one one
somewhere which is a good label and then
zero on everywhere else
and then yeah since somebody wants this
since they're disabled
satisfies at every level constraint then
yeah we can see that the constraints the
these are constraints linear constraints
are satisfied
if you look at the yellow um
buckets here
then the sum is like one sum is one so
it's good and then if you look at red
buckets here sum is zero sum is zero so
that is satisfied as well
okay so this is like satisfied um when
you have a dictator of corresponding to
good label offer label cover
um
and then yeah then given this our final
reduction is simply um f1 transpose pf1
again like f1 is like the
projection to the linear part
of the boolean function and then p is a
projection
um to
just like the space defined by label
cover
okay so then yeah in one case is a pst
so this is um reduction from nucleotide
and then of course
and then in subatomia one can see that
this also allows like some other like um
unintended vectors in subspace as well
because if you look at um
these are these vectors
then yeah the sum for um yellow is three
yellow is three which is good and the
sum for red is five
red is 5 okay so even though this is
exactly not the intended standard
effector this is can be like in the
substrates as well
that's why it's like the reductions are
not really exact
yeah but anyway so but anyone can still
try to analyze it with this reaction
but then now it looks much more
complicated because like this like
compression of operator p
is kind of global
it concerns the entire like the inverses
at once
okay so it seems like very hard to
analyze but then yeah but then one slick
trick
that we're going to use
is the following of that
okay so by using the normal duality
and then
and then the fact that a can be
decomposed
as like f1 transpose like p transpose p
at one because like p is a projection
anyway so then yeah one can say that
instead of writing our like val optimal
value as this
we can also write down the optimal value
as this
where we are searching over that um
the vector f prime it's like two numbers
one
and then we are trying to maximize the
one node
over f f one p f prime
okay so yeah there's like one norm uh
matches this infinity over here so
that's where like normal duality comes
from
um
but then yeah if you believe this
then the analysis like um goes on this
way
that offer any like f prime looks like
two numbers one
then the only thing we need from this
projection operator
is that it doesn't um increase the two
number for sure because it's a
projection
and then and after applying projection
then of course like
the p times f5 will be in the subspace
that is consistent with this cup
okay so using only these two tags
actually one can analyze
um
um the pyrite reduction using um kind of
test machinery
and then then one can say that p is a
kinetic buildable but then somebody else
is bypassed
okay so yeah that was like the pirate to
hard destruction by um briefed the
regular socket
but then of course we want to go beyond
pi over two
um and then that's our reduction okay so
our reduction is like simple as well so
this is our our entire reduction which
is um the pi over two part
seven transpose pf one
minus lambda times i for like some
lambda
which will be determined
yeah
um and then yeah one can say this is uh
it's a
as exact the same form as a diabetes
operator for indicators though like our
analysis that could not match like their
number we had to lose like more
uh and then the completeness is obvious
okay so if um there's a good labeling or
like um label cover instance
then yeah as usual i'm going to let down
the boolean function
of 4v
fv
as a dictator function which is dictated
by the coordinate corresponding to the
good label for b
if you do this then yeah then i af is um
exactly one minus um lambda times f
then the value becomes momentum
of course like the more interesting part
is solvents
um and then suppose that yeah we have
like solution um gnf okay so we are in
the sound this case so that label covers
not a good instance and then suppose
that g and f are optimal for our um
reduction
then let's even say that f prime
is um the p times f on f
and the g prime's like p times f of g
okay so then essentially the previous
analysis for pi over two implies that
they are like shorter to begin with so
the length of a prime and g prime
are both at most like square root over
pi
um
then
if you look at um
this like form here
then we can also think about the win-win
analysis which is similar to w reads but
then slightly more complicated
okay so the two cases that we're going
to look at
is when like f and g are like close
okay so for example like f and g are all
these unit vectors so that the close
meaning that they are like inner product
is large
okay so if from the f and g um have a
inner product um
greater than 0.9
then then yeah one can see that actually
we are done because like sounds will be
low
okay so one way to see this is that if
you look at the g transpose a f
this one can um
decompose this as like the inner product
between g prime and f prime
minus lambda times the inner product in
general
because the definition of f prime energy
prime
okay but then anyway we know that the
first term
is at most of two over pi because like
individually f prime and g prime are not
that long
and then you are left with the minus
lambda times actually
f
uh but then if um the g and f are closed
if their inner product is big
then you're subtracting a lot
okay so we are subtracting like um 0.9
lambda from the two over pi
so then this on this value
will be at most over pi minus 0.9 number
but then yeah one can see that
so then the other ratio is like um
greater than pi over 2 okay so i'm
crucially using that 0.9 here
is a greater than 2 over pi
so the um the completeness value
is uh decreased by lambda but then sound
and button sound is value is also
decreased by something close to lambda
okay so that the ratio between them
actually is increased
okay so this is the first case when f
and g are kind of um
close enough
but then yeah for the other case
if i if you look at f prime and g prime
okay which concerns the first term here
then if like f prime and g prime are
like far apart
then yeah one can see the first term
it's gonna hurt anyway and then the
soundness will be uh bad
okay so forget for example if you look
at the if you assume that the l2 skirt
distance
between a prime and g prime
are at least four times lambda then yeah
by just like a simple calculation and
then one can say the inner product
between f prime and g prime
is at most of two over pi minus two
lambda
um
so that yeah no matter what you got from
the second term
lambda times the gf
then the soundness value will be at most
october pi minus lambda
and then we will be done as well
okay so then our goal
is to show that whether like this
happens
or like this happens
okay so that's our goal
okay so yeah we formally we want to show
that if from f prime and g prime
uh they're like l2 distance is at most
lambda then
uh the l2 distance between f and g are
at most point
yeah suppose this is like um what do we
want to show
if we want to um finish the proof
okay good um
and then now we are in a good situation
f uh and f prime should be similar g and
g prime should be similar from these
definitions
but then again
but then again we have this problem
that um
i mean it's so it's uh the
outcome of applying like two um
operators f1 and p and then price like p
is more problematic because like p is
kind of global um operator okay so how
can you relate f g and f prime g prime
so that's um the challenge
okay so this is um
the goal we want to prove
but then the first of all
actually one can um assume that for like
each v or like for almost all versus v
though if you look at the fd prime and
the gd prime
then like these two vectors should have
a like um similar like l2 norm
and then they are all that constant
it's not too crazy like really high or
like not crazily small and they're like
far from dictators
if one can assume that thinking apart
from dictators is kind of unexpected
um because like we are in the sound this
case
uh but then yeah how can you show that
um
um fv prime and the gd prime have like
similar length okay looking like if it's
uh it's a simple analysis uh but then
like it's kind of global
because one can show that
if f b uh prime g and gv prime have a
different length
then it just like should mean that f
prime and g v g prime
should be far like global
okay so yeah that's um just like simple
fact and then this can this is gonna um
contradict the assumption that we made
okay so then yeah one can see that then
okay so then that a prime and gv prime
should have a similar length for most
vertices
uh but then still how do you connect
fgnf prime g prime
okay so the crucial another critical
observation that we use
is that g is optimal uh given m
okay so then yeah then it means that if
by the definition of a here
then it means that g
should be the sine
over f prime minus lambda
and then similarly
f should be the sine of a g prime minus
lambda g
because i get whenever the f is decided
so that f prime is decided
then like g
should be like plus minus function that
maximizes a bi-linear product
which will be the sign of the
uh these guys
okay
okay so then yeah then that's the
connection uh between like um f of g and
f g from g prime okay so instead of
directly relating f and f prime we're
kind of doing this like zigzag
relation
okay so yeah
then
we can show we can show lemma
uh saying that since some g
is a um sine over f prime minus x some
perturbation we're gonna like say like
lambda some small constant then yeah one
can formally bound the distance between
g and the sine of f prime
by like um let's say root lambda
and then
and then by standard argument then we
can also show that the sine of f prime
and sine of g prime
are like closed if f prime and g prime
are close
and then if you combine everything
then yeah one can show that if f prime
and g prime are closed
then one can see that so distance
between f and g
is at most the distance between f and um
sine of g prime
and then the g n sine of f prime
and then the sine of y prime and g prime
yeah but then yeah but these two things
are covered by our lemma 2 here
and then the final term is covered by
our lemma 3.
okay so then yeah one can say that okay
so if f prime and g prime are close
enough then f and g
must be close enough
which is exactly um what we wanted to
show
for our window analysis
and we are done
and then at least like then at this
point yeah then we see that at least
one can shape like some constant
from pi over two and then that's exactly
what we did
okay so that's the kind of the idea of
the whole proof
and then yeah so um again of course the
obvious open problem
is to get the better npr this for good
ending
okay so yeah as we mentioned our
reduction is exactly the same as
diabetes with different values lambda
but then our analysis was quite lossy
okay so the product the first open
problem
is to see whether like our analysis can
be strengthened uh to match this
diabetes lower points
um and then as we mentioned so that's
like techniques like slightly like
global okay so we are going to look at
the f and g vectors which is like n
times like two to the right diminished
vectors
and then see um and then the kind of
global behavior vectors
uh to prove something
so then uh second question is which is
more general question
is whether like um this technique so
projection to label cover subspace plus
like some kind of global like geometric
analysis
so can it help offer other problems as
well
okay so that's all i have to say and
thank you